[Musique]
1721 mon trésor à celui qui saura le
prendre tels serai les derniers mots du
célèbre pirate labuse juste avant son
exécution à Saint-Paul en
1730 né en 1695 à Cala Olivier Levasseur
élevé par un grand-père marin s'engage
dans la marine marchande à l'âge de 15
ans
à partir de 1716 on retrouve sa trace
comme pirate dans les Caraïbes où il se
fait appeler l'abuse du fait de la
rapidité de ses attaques après avoir
écumé l'ouest de l'Afrique il fait le
choix de l'océan Indien en 1721 il
s'empare de la Vierge du Cap imposant
vaisseau Royal portugais en réparation
dans la rate de
Saint la cargaison de diamants de perles
d'épic ou de bois précieux et d'une
valeur inestimable à cela s'ajoute une
rançon pour la libération du viceroi des
Indes qui trouvé à bord pour mettre fin
à la piraterie la Compagnie des Indes
propose une amnestie au pirates en 1724
mais laabuse s'y refuse et il finit par
être arrêté à Madagascar c'est à la
Réunion qu'il est jugé puis pendu le 7
juillet 1730 après avoir lancé un
mystérieux cryptogramme à la foule
depuis plus de 3 siècles son trésor et
ses mystères passionnent les réonnais et
les chasseurs de trésors dans l'océan
Indien 1721 le pirate labus s'empare de
la Vierge
UK
[Musique]